il
la semaine dernière nous avons laissé
les kings cas nous les retrouvons
aujourd'hui très occupé à pêcher vous le
voyez une pêche avec désinvolture avec
majesté même inlassablement une chute
leur harpe ont vu ce qu'est ce qu'il
transperce un poisson s'il n'en
transperce pas avec mon dieu tant pis si
l'un transperça ils sont ravis ici tout
est logique
le corps de liens confectionne les
cordes celles ci sont réservés warp la
vache est un signe de richesse aussi a
tout intérêt à nettoyer très
publiquement sa peau après avoir ignoré
totalement sa viande la viande il ne la
mange jamais la page deviendra un sujet
de conversation pour salon chez les
dinka on parle vaches comme à londres on
parle du derby d'epsom de méthodes de
piler le mil
voici la seconde elle est hystérique
photo de famille précédent vous allez
voir celle de cette côte et dinka qui
est la plus élégante de chambre b
puisque nous sommes à chambé au beau
milieu des marais de bas elle je perde
nous entrons dans les marais le sauver
d'une nombreux explorateurs depuis 50
ans ce sont les français qui ont ouvert
les premiers la voix mais depuis des
millénaires
vous allez voir ce qu'ils habitaient là
e
des papillons
une mante religieuse double de celle que
nous trouvons chez nous
voici les oiseaux bec ouvert c'est une
façon comme une autre de chasser
rapidement le shah khan us dont les
doigts de pieds sont très longs aussi
l'oncle corse qui lui permet de marcher
sur les nénuphars l'ibis sacré des
anciens égyptiens des hérons gros gris
et des grues couronnées
ce sont des animaux domestiques dans
l'egypte ancienne qui sont de grands
jeux des échassiers 80 cm de haut voici
l'oiseau bec de chaussures
il est curieux c'est un animal temps et
sentimentale très sentimental est d'une
lenteur
ça n'est pas un ralenti ils sont pleins
habituelles voilà la poche pour les
caméras
c'est dans le pays de shillouk que nous
rencontrons cette nouvelle race
soudanaise
quant au fleuve lui bien il sort va tout
droit vers le nord je une immense plaine
de 800 kilomètres
le vent du nord soulève des vagues
leschi looks sont de race noble
puisqu'ils ont droit à la peau les os
par yamina la perfection et parade des
guerres d'autrefois avec la caméra il
est facile de franchir des centaines de
kilomètres et nous nous retrouvons
beaucoup plus au nord cette fois nous
avons affaire au pêcheur nubien c'est
une autre race soudanaise
là le fleuve atteint 25 km de large
poussé par le vent ils déferlent comme
la mer dont leur encontre
vous voyez il est très agité et c'est le
désert de nubie l'a23 série de rapides
et de cataracte succèdent cobra petit
animal charmant il ornait les temples de
l'ancienne egypte
le punk harder la puce sales bêtes du
bassin du nil
venant de la mer rouge les à dender ils
ont couché leurs chameaux à travers le
désert jusqu'au fleuve bien décidé ainsi
rafraîchir
nous croisons maintenant les premiers
ruined influence égyptiennes elles ne
sont pas l'egypte sienne
quand
toujours très agitée
le limon se déposer la culture reprend
et lan piétine le résultat de cette
culture
ainsi le grain de blé sortira de lippi
c'est dans cette région est à peu près à
ce moment que nos amis ont mangé des
tripes cru poivre est très exactement
maintenant et la courtoisie a exigé
qu'ils aillent jusqu'au bout
nous leur souhaitons bon appétit
et
pas du tout ce n'est pas de l'eau c'est
du sable du sable chassé par le vent
rapide et cataractes deviennent de plus
en plus difficile et il fait 52,2 gré
simple à l'ombre presque rien
c'était à prévoir un bateau a chaviré
mais c'est une catastrophe parce que les
sacs étanches était mal fermée
c'est une erreur qui leur a coûté de
nombreuses heures de patience pour
démonter et remonter les appareils de
prise de vue les roches ont été cruels
et il faut réparer et voilà ce que l'on
peut s'offrir dans le désert de nubie
il ya ici tellement de canard que même à
bâle on est sûrs d'augmenter le repas du
soir du déjeuner faut tout pourquoi pas
gras dans le sable et vous allez voir
que l'on va trouver quelque chose
quelques oeufs de tortue exactement
comme des balles de ping pong comestible
par exemple
préparent le déjeuner
en plein soleil et après mon dieu il
faut faire la vaisselle
pour
le fleuve entre de l'an dans le baht el
haggar ce qui veut dire le ventre de la
pierre cette région 8 aride le soleil
torride
la leur nez et se sont brûlés et la peau
de leurs mains se sont dit s'est
détachée d'elle-même
paysage est vraiment très beau
là il faut subir l'épreuve du portal
c'est la plus grande cataractes du nil
épreuve particulièrement pénible parce
que les roches sont brûlants et
l'ambiance est celle d'une étude les
nubiens se chausse de sandales de paille
pour éviter les brûlures et ils sont
habitués au climat la température à la
chaleur ou penser ce qu'on dû endurer
nos explorateurs
voici où champollion est venue après
avoir traduit les hiéroglyphes et mon
dieu c'est à lui que nous devons quatre
mille ans d'histoire
je
comment